how are you i'm good how are you
three-time nominee but you haven't won
but i feel like tonight could be your
night android oh come on don't say that
i'm trying to just have a good time i
don't want to worry about having to get
up there like no i'm i'm just grateful
to be here and that's the truth and i
love this film i love this character i
love this company of actors and
tonight's about community tonight's
about you know us loving each other in
this community while there's so much
love that needs to be sent to ukraine
right now and so hopefully we can create
some energy and support them and
advocate for them from afar in the small
ways that we're able to tonight yes and
this is a little distraction from all
that going on sure
you're also nominated for critics choice
but also an oscar yeah you're having
quite quite a season i'm very lucky i'm
lucky that i get to tell stories i'm
lucky that i get to act i wanted to do
this since i was a kid so to be stood
here talking to you guys is an honor and
let's talk about you guys breaking the
internet with the meme
what who whose idea was that how did you
guys come up with that oh no it was
always going to happen i think everyone
was like how do we do the meme how do we
do the meme so we so before we shot
anything we just did a photo shoot of
the three of us pointing at each other
and i think they must have got one
good shot because we were all just
cracking up so much we couldn't quite
contain ourselves so yeah i mean yeah
when did you guys shoot that how long
have you been keeping it a secret oh god
i mean gosh a year ago now yeah yeah
so wild well tom holland did recently
say that one of you guys wore a fake
butt on set so i need to know i heard
this who had the fake butt andrew well i
have no idea it's not not me so i have
no clue i don't want to like i don't
want to i don't know i assumed
everyone's butts were their butts so
it's not you it's not tom so i guess i'm
not i don't think it's totally i've seen
toby's butt toby's toby's got back
so you're reuniting tonight with jamie
dornan who also is a nominee boy my
brother yeah we just saw each other i
love him how does it feel to reunite
well it's share a moment like this with
him like to share any moment with jamie
just makes me happy because i just love
being around him but um to see the work
that he's done in the last couple of
years and to see him being honored is
just like i'm just so proud of him he's
such a beautiful man a beautiful actor
not only in belfast but in barbin star
maybe my most favorite film of the last
20 years and his performance is just
pure
silliness and joy so i love him and you
know it's so wonderful to share these
moments with actual friends and i love
this suit give me a little secret about
this look oh well this is a santa rosa
and i
you know it's a little vintagey kind of
custom thing and yeah i mean i just dig
it i dig that stuff so much and this is
yeah it feels nice like i'm wearing a
nice fitting glove for myself right now